well the scale of the scientific
achievement is truly unprecedented what
has happened
and it is really the result of the
spectacular advances
in technological capability
to develop vaccine platforms in a way
that have us being able to do things in
weeks to months that literally would
have taken a decade ago
years and years to do and it has nothing
to do with compromising
scientific integrity or compromising
safety
of volunteers in the vaccine trial it's
just that an extraordinary advances
in technologies that actually have taken
place over years and years but finally
culminated in the technology that has
allowed us
to go from identifying a virus in
january
of 2020 and then less than one year
later
to actually have vaccine doses ready to
go into people
as you will soon be doing in the uk so
it just is something that is totally
unprecedented well you mentioned races
and the the race to develop a vaccine
now as you
also touch on there there's a race to
get one approved and it seems the uk has
won that race
in terms of its being the first country
uh in the world to
approve a vaccine that's passed its
third stage of clinical trials
do you think that is because the uk has
been more agile than for instance the
united states or is it premature
you know i think it's very important for
people to realize
that there are different levels of
stringency and scrutiny upon which you
look at the data
the the fda in the united states i think
everyone realizes globally is the gold
standard
of regulatory function
where here in the united states as i'm
sure is somewhat in the uk
there is this degree of skepticism on
the part of the people about wanting to
take a vaccine thinking that perhaps
it was done too quickly perhaps it isn't
as safe and effective as we say they are
so we put the data through a very very
stringent process of literally point by
point
analyzing the data the uk has decided
to do it a little bit differently
they've gone over it very quickly
and i can say and this is not a
criticism but they've done it in a way
that has much
less deep than has been done that is
being done
by the fda in the united states in fact
i i as as i hear from the news
other members of people in the european
union have actually criticized
the uk for going so quickly i don't want
to get into criticism or who's right or
who's wrong
it's just a different degree of scrutiny
our
examination of the data will be complete
very likely in a week and a half
so we will likely have pfizer data ready
to go
for an eua which is an emergency use
authorization
by the 11th of uh december
the moderna product likely by the 18th
of december so we don't look upon it as
a race of who
won the race the product is there
the trial was done the data look really
good
quite efficacious and i believe quite
safe and it's just a matter of
what kind of scrutiny each country's
regulatory agency
puts the data through that's all that
really is
but it is an important point you make
about um the speed because of course as
you're going to tell me later i'm sure
it is important that uh when the vaccine
becomes widely available that as many
people as possible
take it and there is as you touch on
there a degree of
vaccine skepticism in some countries
quite a large degree of that
and if the regulatory process is
seen to be or thought to be too quick
are you saying it might
feed into that skepticism
yes uh absolutely and that's one of the
things we're really concerned about
because we have here and the uk will
benefit it from it the way all of the
world will
we have a couple of highly efficacious
vaccines but the effectiveness of a
vaccine program
is only as good as the number of people
who actually get vaccinated
and when we did a survey here in the
united states
there was a considerable degree of
skepticism and reluctance
to get vaccinated and we were concerned
that if we did anything that looked like
it was cutting corners
that would feed into the skepticism and
we might have
the effect which would really be the
opposite of what we want
namely that less people would want to
get vaccinated
so we want to put it through the process
that's the standard process
we're hurrying it up a bit but not
nearly as quickly
as you did in the uk which we believe if
we had done that
here in the united states it would have
been to our disadvantage
because it would have generated a lot of
skepticism
about the speed with which it was
approved and can i just put you your
contention dr fauci that the fda the
food and drugs administration is the
gold standard
of regulatory authorities it's not what
the british government thinks you may be
aware that a british government minister
sits in the cabinet alongside prime
minister boris johnson
said the reason why the uk was able to
approve
this vaccine because it's got the best
medical regulators
much better than the americans because
it's a much better country
yeah well okay let me start off by
saying i love all you people in the uk
i have so many friends there but i don't
want to get into that who won
what race first that this is a serious
enough thing
that we've all got to pull together on
this and not look like we're trying to
out-compete each other
okay uh well can i ask you about other
vaccines coming down the track and this
one does have a
a big british stamp on it and it's the
astrazeneca oxford
efforts um and it's a different route of
developing the vaccines a more
traditional one and adenovirus as i
understand it as opposed to the
mrna ones we've been talking about do
you think that it
has the potential to be to be less
effective
you know we don't know until you try it
i i believe that
of all of the vaccines that are being
tried the united states
is involved in supporting directly and
indirectly six
of these one of them is the astrozenica
candidate that is being tested right now
as we speak
here in the united states i believe that
given
the high degree of efficacy that we have
seen with the
mrna and i hope and believe that
we will see a comparable efficacy with
the other candidates but it remains to
be seen when you're dealing with the
development of vaccines
the proof of the pudding is going to be
the result of the clinical trial
so when the results of the clinical
trial come out then we'll be able to see
just how comparable these results will
be
but there are some suggestions that uh
some of the big pharmaceutical companies
that have developed other vaccines like
fires we've been discussing moderna
and others don't like the astrazeneca
effort because it's so
cheap and might undercut them
no i don't think that's the case we just
want as many vaccines as we possibly can
we are going to need all of the involved
companies
to finish and go to the finish line and
be a winner there's not just one winner
here
there are multiple ones because if you
look at all of the demands
of vaccines for the world and this is a
global problem
that has to be addressed as a global
problem so we'll need
each and every company that has an
efficacious vaccine
to be in the mix putting out vaccine
doses that people can use so i don't
think
it's a it's an example of one company
not wanting another company to succeed
everybody needs to succeed in order for
us to get this under control
dr fiji tell me how bad the situation is
with kobe 19 in the united states do you
wake up
each morning hoping against hope that
you'll see some better figures
yet time after time they confound you
and they just seem to get worse a
hundred thousand americans now
occupying hospital beds right it's a
very difficult situation here in the
united states
literally and unfortunately every day
we seem to break a record either for
number of cases in a day it goes over
200
000 number of deaths well over two
thousand
close to three thousand a day and as you
said
correctly a hundred thousand
hospitalizations
and it's going to get worse
unfortunately because we are now in the
beginning
of december we're going to see a surge
almost certainly related
to the travel in the congregating during
our thanksgiving
holiday we'll see the result of that two
to three weeks following thanksgiving
which will put us right before the
christmas holiday and the hanukkah
holiday
and what we'll see now is even more
infections as people travel for
christmas and hanukkah
congregate in dinners and social
settings
we're in for a cold long winter
unfortunately we can do something about
it i believe
if we uniformly adhere to public health
measures like uniform wearing of masks
avoiding close contact
avoiding crowds particularly indoor
congregate settings
if we all did that universally we could
blunt
what we're seeing is a very steep surge
of cases
okay and i'm going to ask you why that's
happening and adding into weight talking
about the
the holiday season there i'm reading
something like 20
festive season parties planned in and
around the white house and that question
is
does it have to be this way or would
better leadership have left the united
states
in a better position going into the
winter
well i mean i've said it many many times
it doesn't matter where you are
who you are what your position is when
you have large numbers of people
congregating indoors usually without
masks that is a very high risk
situation that almost inevitably will
lead to a surge in numbers of infections
but i'm talking about president trump
who yesterday i noticed tweeted about
nine
times on the day that as you've been
telling us uh
a record number of deaths were reported
in the united states from kobe 19 the
president's still tweeting about
losing an election through fraud
well i'm not going to comment about
anything that has to do with the
president because then that becomes a
sound bite which is not helpful
to what i really want to do is to stop
infections from spreading throughout the
united states
and the world but i want to talk about
your ability to
influence how the united states handles
covid19 now you going to get involved
we understand you're having meetings
today or may have had meetings with the
the joe biden transition team
yes i will this afternoon we'll be
talking about some of the transition
things that we'd like to see happen so
we could have
a smooth transition from one
administration to another
uh and uh in between time you don't
expect uh the current president to fire
you as we heard his
supporters chanting just before the
election
i don't think that's going to happen i
have a pretty good relationship with the
president so i don't anticipate that
happening